I WANT TO SHARE SOME NOTES, SOME
EDITORIAL SUGGESTIONS THAT WERE
PREPARED AFTER THE SCREENING
OF A -- OF A MOVIE I WAS IN.
OPENING TOO CHOPPY.
WHY IS THIS VOICEOVER
TRACK SO TERRIBLE?
HE SOUNDS DRUGGED.
WERE THEY ALL ON DRUGS?
DECKARD AT THE PIANO
IS INTERMINABLE.
FLASHBACK DIALOGUE CONFUSING.
IS HE LISTENING TO A TAPE?
WHY DO WE NEED THE
THIRD CUT TO THE EGGS?
THE SYNAGOGUE MUSIC
IS AWFUL ON THE STREET,
WE'VE GOT TO USE
VANGELIS.
UP TO ZHORA'S DEATH, THE
MOVIE IS DEADLY DULL.
THIS MOVIE GETS WORSE
EVERY SCREENING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT MOVIE WAS CALLED
"BLADE RUNNER.”
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND THESE NOTES CAN HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHY THE EDITING
PROCESS CAN OFTEN
GET A LITTLE COMPLICATED.
THE POSSIBILITIES MAY SEEM
ENDLESS, BUT THE EDITOR WILL WORK
TIRELESSLY, OFTEN IN ISOLATION,
TO MAKE THOUSANDS OF CHOICES
PLACING THE RIGHT PIECE OF THE
RIGHT LENGTH IN THE RIGHT ORDER
TO ARRIVE AT THE BEST VERSION OF
WHAT THE MOVIE WANTS TO BE.
IT'S AN EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
PROCESS, NOT FOR THE IMPATIENT
NOT FOR THE FAINT OF HEART.
YOU'VE GOT TO REALLY
LOVE MAKING MOVIES.
TONIGHT'S NOMINEES FOR
BEST FILM EDITING ARE --
"THE FATHER,"
YORGOS LAMPRINOS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
"NOMADLAND,"
CHLOE ZHAO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
"PROMISING YOUNG WOMAN,"
FREDERIC THORAVAL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
"SOUND OF METAL,"
MIKKEL E.G. NIELSEN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND "THE TRIAL OF THE
CHICAGO 7," ALAN BAUMGARTEN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
"SOUND OF METAL"
MIKKEL E.G. NIELSEN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU,
THANK YOU ACADEMY.
AND FELLOW NOMINEES,
YOU’RE AN INSPIRATION TO ME.
I’M FROM DENMARK,
AND I WOULD LIKE TO
GREET DENMARK BECAUSE
THEY ARE EXTREMELY
BOLD AT FUNDING
THE DANISH FILM SCHOOL
SO WE STUDENTS CAN
DEVELOP OUR CRAFT AND
LANGUAGE FOR FOUR YEARS.
IT’S AMAZING.
THIS IS WHAT YOU GET, SO
JUST CONTINUE DOING IT.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
EVE AND ANGUS
AND MY AMAZING
ASSISTANT ALEX.
AND MY WHOLE FAMILY AT
ROCK PAPER SCISSORS.
YOU GUYS RAISED THE BAR.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
MY AGENTS, HILLARY AND REBECCA.
AMAZON AND CAVIAR
AND EVERYONE FROM
CAST AND CREW FOR SHARING
YOUR ENORMOUS TALENTS.
THE DEAF COMMUNITY
FOR INVITING ME IN
VERY INSPIRING AND
REWARDING WORLDS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ALL MY FRIENDS, MY FAMILIES,
MY PARENTS, I HAVE TO
REMEMBER MY PARENTS.
MY SISTERS, MY WIFE JUDITH
AND MY KIDS MINGUS AND ELLA.
THEY ALWAYS ALLOW ME
TO SPEND TIME WITH
MY BIG LOVE AFFAIR:
EDITING.
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
BUT ONE ABOVE ALL,
DARIUS MARDER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE VISION.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
ON THIS LIFE-CHANGING,
I WOULD SAY, JOURNEY.
AND IT’S BEEN LIKE FOLLOWING
A RAINBOW FOR ME
AND TODAY I FEEL LIKE
WE FOUND THE GOLD.
THANK YOU.